[Música]
fue hace exactamente 10 años la primera
vez que yo escuché las palabras
computación y no en la misma oración y
desde que entendía que se trataba la
computación en la nube comencé a
estudiarla soy un apasionado por ella al
punto que mi esposa con frecuencia me
dice que mi cabeza pasa en las nubes y
voy a admitirlo quizás tenga mucho de
razón parte lo que mis invasiones han
arrojado sin embargo es entender que en
la región latinoamericana y en costa
rica en particular no estamos sacando
tanto provecho a la nube como deberíamos
lo cual me lleva a la pregunta que
traigo para ustedes hoy porque no
estamos utilizando en la nube ahora
antes de entrar en porque lo usamos o
porque no vale la pena discutir qué es
la nube lo primero que me gustaría
aclarar es que la nube no es un lugar
con nosotros decimos que nuestros datos
están en la nube no nos referimos a que
están allá arriba en la estratosfera a
algún lugar celestial no nos referimos a
que nuestros datos están en manos de
algún proveedor de servicios en la nube
y este proveedor tiene centros de datos
y lo que este programa nos vende ese
espacio almacenamiento procesamiento
memoria ram y en todo este sentido lo
que nosotros vamos a conseguir una nube
no es una tecnología nueva es el mismo
hardware el mismo software que hemos
venido consumiendo por décadas
ahora bien si no es una tecnología algo
al haber nuevo en la nube tal que me
haya yo avocado los últimos diez años a
estudiarla y la mejor forma de expresar
para mí que esa nube es decir la nube es
un servicio y aquí me refiero con esto
un servicio algo que se consume no algo
que se compra y una buena analogía para
entender cómo consumimos un servicio es
el servicio de agua que tenemos en
nuestros hogares
nosotros cuando requerimos agua en
nuestros hogares por ejemplo para
ducharnos que hacemos abrimos la llave
cuando terminamos de ducharnos cerramos
la llave si estamos lavando los trastes
los platos si requerimos más agua
abrimos un poco más la llave y en todo
momento consumimos exactamente la
cantidad de agua que requerimos al fin
de mes el probar nos va a cobrar
entonces exactamente por la cantidad de
recursos que consumimos ni una gota más
ni una gota menos de la misma forma lo
que la nube nos permite es consumir
recursos computacionales y pagar
únicamente por aquellos recursos que
nosotros necesitemos ya sea de jugar
creo sea de soft comparemos esto con el
modelo tradicional
aquel modelo donde nosotros compramos el
equipo con tracción al y todo está en
nuestro centro de datos y una decisión
importantísima tomar es de qué tamaño
requiere yo este servidor cuánta
capacidad necesito hagamos un ejercicio
breve de pizarra
lo que un ingeniero haría es estimar a
lo largo del año cuál es la demanda que
por recursos que tengo sube y baja
alrededor del año y un buen ingeniero va
a estimar el pico y compra un poquito
más pagamos una situación hipotética de
por el momento donde la capacidad
instalada no siempre supera la demanda
que ocurre en el tiempo durante una
buena parte del año tenemos capacidad
ociosa espacios ocupados
esto significa que mi servidor yo es tan
holgados y puedo seguir trabajando pero
habrán picos de demanda donde de pronto
tengo demanda insatisfecha que significa
demanda satisfecha esto es que el
sistema está frenado el sistema está
saturado que no puedo procesar
transacciones que mi empresa no puede
facturar que los visitantes de mi sitio
web de comercio electrónico no
encuentran el sitio web esto es
realmente grave y pronto que los
ingenieros muy sabiamente siempre
compramos más de lo que necesitamos
porque creemos que es mejor que sobre a
que no a lo que falte sin embargo aún
con esta previsión realmente estamos
cometiendo un gran error porque las
estadísticas sugieren que los servidores
computacionales usualmente utilizan
entre 16 15% esa capacidad eso quiere
decir que hay 85 por ciento de la
capacidad del servidor que está en
desuso
justamente por este sobre estimación que
hacemos los ingenieros esto tiene muy
poco sentido porque pienso esto es como
haber comprado un avión gigantesco y
volarlo con todos los costos que
hablarlo conlleva y sin embargo solo
tener de 10 a 15 por ciento los asientos
llenos todo el resto del dinero que
estamos desperdiciando ahora porque es
que sobrestimamos porque yo no puedo
comprar recursos no puedo abrir la llave
cuando sea que lo necesita sino que lo
tengo que haber comprado por adelantado
y esto lo que la nube viene a cambiar al
yo poder abrir y será la llave dios
tenga la capacidad de equiparar mi
demanda por recursos computacionales con
mi capacidad instalada algunos ejemplos
de empresas nacionales que han hecho
esto de entidad nacional es uno es el
tribunal supremo elecciones cuando eran
las elecciones que ganó don guillermo
solís ellos estimaron que ocupaban unos
dos servidores para atender las
consultas de los ciudadanos que querían
ver como yo en las elecciones sin
embargo cuando llegó el evento ellos no
requiere un 2 sino que apenas requieren
el 70% del primero los servidores para
suerte de ellos ellos estaban corriendo
en una plataforma no y entonces pudieron
apagar o en los servidores
ahorraron básicamente a la mitad de los
costos luego vinieron las elecciones
municipales y pasó algo muy interesante
yo dijeron ya aprendí que sólo necesito
un servidor pero sistema se comporta de
manera distinta a los ciudadanos nos
comportamos de manera distinta y más
bien requerimos entre 10 y 15 veces la
capacidad que teníamos instalada
nuevamente el tribunal que estaba
haciendo uso infraestructura de un
proveedor aquí en costa rica de la nube
llamó el proveedor le digo por favor
levántame 10 15 es la cantidad de
servidores que tengo estaban abriendo la
llave y los ciudadanos ni nos dimos
cuenta que esos eso dio por de clase el
sistema funciona de perfección
otra empresa aquí en costa rica que
utiliza la nube de semac o semana que
utiliza otro problema no en y en la
industria que está se marco de venta al
detalle todos sabemos que hay picos muy
claros en la época de navidad san
valentín díaz las madres y otros por ahí
ellos saben cuándo van a tener estos
picos a nada manda llaman a su operador
de la nube levanta en la infraestructura
necesaria aguantan todo el tráfico de
datos que necesitan y después de esto
vuelven a bajar esto lo que la nube
permite que no podíamos estar antes
porque antes sólo podíamos comprar o
todo o nada ocupamos el servidor
grandote
ahora esto no sólo aplica para casos
donde tenemos demandas elásticas también
aplica para la situación donde tenemos
incertidumbre y en este sentido la nube
nos permite a nosotros experimentar
y hasta la unidad empresarial más
pequeña hasta el innovador más pequeño
hasta el individuo más pequeño gracias a
la nube tiene acceso a recursos
computacionales que antes eran la
envidia de grandes corporaciones esto lo
que nos dice house vea bien economista
de stanford y la persona detrás de los
modelos económicos de google alguien que
realmente sabe de lo que está hablando y
esto lo que nos permite básicamente
experimentar e innovar sin un costo
porque porque en lugar de tener que
comprar un show de una licencia entera
yo puedo suscribirme por un mes en lugar
de comprar un servidor de cinco mil
dólares yo puedo comenzar pagando 50
horas al mes por un servidor mucho más
pequeño si mi proyecto crece yo comienza
a avanzar entonces comienzo a crecer y
levantó más servidor espacio 50 a 100 a
200 dólares al mes si mi proyecto está
creciendo es porque las cosas van bien
por mi proyecto como proyecto que era de
innovación y experimentación también
puede fracasar qué hago yo cierro la
llave y un aumento que yo cáncer la
suscripción o apago los servidores dejó
de pagar por ello en este sentido lo que
la nube está haciendo es sacando el
riesgo financiero de innovar ya yo
necesito ir a pedir presupuesto nada
necesita la misma plática para el
almuerzo me la llevo de la caja chica y
con eso comenzamos a innovar en la nube
nuestro gobierno
hace unos años tuve esta visión y en el
2003 se emitió una directriz que para
todas las instituciones públicas que
decían para cualquier nuevo proyecto
tecnologías de información nosotros
deberíamos privilegiar infraestructura
en la nube por sobre el modelo
tradicional que habíamos comentado ahora
si la no es tan poderosa uno esperaría
que todos estemos utilizando la nube
para que investigadores realmente que
tanto estamos utilizando la nube y con
base una encuesta que venía haciendo los
últimos años yo estimo que alrededor de
un 75% de las organizaciones en la
región están utilizando infraestructura
en la nube para satisfacción de muchos
de lo que estamos en esta sala hoy el
número costarricense es ligeramente más
alto y estimó que alrededor del 85% de
las empresas de costa rica están
utilizando la nube ahora para mí esto es
un número muy muy bueno tan bueno que
algo raro ha de tener investiga un poco
más me puso a investigar qué es lo que
estamos utilizando en la nube y la nube
podemos hablar de distintos tipos de
servicios uno de ellos son lo que
conocemos como software como servicio
aplicaciones que ya están listas para
ser utilizadas que nada más donde
tenemos a una página web y comenzamos a
utilizar tus servicios
popular por mucho es correo electrónico
al utilizar gmail o out lo que en línea
nosotros realmente estamos dando la nube
porque pagamos con base en la cantidad
de usuarios activos que tenemos o con
base en la cantidad almacenada que
requiere cada una esas cuentas de
correos cuando yo tengo menos usuarios
los des escribo y pago menos cuando
tengo más usuarios inscribió más y pago
más aplica lo de pago por uso otra
aplicación sumamente popular entre
nosotros son servicios como el propio
google drive de almacenamiento privado
que potencialmente es lo primero es el
bien ustedes a la cabeza con dijeron mis
datos están a no es mis datos están en
raid mis datos están en robots esto es
muy popular pero realmente no es
emocionante porque es que no es
emocionante porque aquí yo no puedo
crear mis propias aplicaciones no estoy
experimentando realmente solo estoy
consumiendo sí como un servicio pago por
uso algo que alguien más ya hizo la
parte más emocionante la nube tiene que
ver con infraestructura subyacente
cuando yo comienzo a arrendar recursos
para innovar y si en aquella misma
encuesta que les conté excluimos show
first servers software como servicios de
los números la tasa de opción cae cae
alrededor de uno
el 40 por ciento para la región para
costa rica y 30 por ciento para la
región nate americana y una idea mira
esto no es tan mal sin embargo a nivel
mundial en latitudes más al norte este
número ya özil el 90 por ciento
claramente nos estamos quedando atrás y
esto me lleva a mí a la siguiente
pregunta que son aquellas barreras que
están impidiendo que nosotros realmente
saquemos provecho de la nube la
principal barrera es falta capacitación
no entendemos qué es la nube y es un
temor que tiene muchísimo sentido yo no
voy a temer intuitivamente voy a temer y
no voy a ir a aquello que desconozco a
esto cómo se resuelve aprendiendo un
poco más y en alguna medida a mí me
alegra que sea un tema falta de
capacitación porque significa que yo
tengo un empleo asegurado por los
cuántos años más hablando sobre la nube
cuál es la siguiente barrera mencionada
por las empresas seguridad tememos por
la seguridad de nuestros datos en la
nube y seguridad tiene varias
dimensiones primero en tema psicológico
físico donde yo creo que los datos están
más seguros si están aquí a la par mía
aquí si están afuera en algún lugar
donde algunos estos proveedores yo he
visitado los centros de datos de estos
proveedores tanto en eeuu
como el de lis aquí en costa rica y
otros privados aquí en costa rica
y créanme son centros de datos de
primerísima calidad son tan tan buenos
que a mí más bien me da miedo tener mi
datos solo mi computadora solo mi
servidor y no que estén en los centros
de datos de estas grandes corporaciones
nosotros podemos tener ingenieros en
seguridad que saben mucha seguridad y se
estudiaron todos los libros pero estas
empresas tienen a la gente que escribe
estos libros ellos realmente saben lo
que están haciendo y eso lo que respecta
a seguridad física otra dimensión
también la seguridad lógica a que el
temor que alguien hackeó me roben mis
datos en la nube lo que aplica en este
caso es una modelo de responsabilidad
compartida donde el proveedor me pueda
dar a mí herramientas tecnológicas para
resguardar mi información a muy bajo
costo vale mencionar pero en sí mi
contraseña para guardar mis datos es
123456 realmente no hay nada que el
proveedor puede hacer por nosotros
entonces las mismas políticas ahora que
yo tengo localmente me las puedo llevar
la nube y así realmente resguardar mis
datos
otra barrera mencionada por las empresas
es un alto costo y tiene mucho sentido
si nosotros tratamos de levantar el
mismo servidor que utilizamos hoy en
nuestro centro de datos en la nube pero
estamos cometiendo un gravísimo error al
pensar así porque estoy tratando
básicamente utilizar el mismo avión
gigantesco que vuelo en gran medida
desocupado que es localmente estoy
tratando hablar la nube cuando a la nube
llama tiempo de ir a comprar una
avioneta una avioneta de estas
pequeñitas que vayan al líder ya que me
lleve lo suficiente para la mayor parte
del año y cuando tengo más pasajeros lo
que hago es conseguir más avionetas y
voy escalando mi demanda entonces
aprovechando la escalera de la nube
nosotros podemos bajar los costos y
realmente aprovechar las bondades
económicas de la nube vale mencionar por
temas de economía de escala incluso
puede que ya el mismo serbio el mismo
avión grandote o el de la misma avioneta
nos cueste realmente menos en la nube
que si la compramos otro localmente por
un tema de economía de escala las
siguientes barreras que les voy a
mencionar son barreras que nos atañen
mucho a nosotros como país
la primera es una limitación de
telecomunicaciones lo cual tiene
muchísimo sentido en toda la región
latinoamericana lamentablemente tenemos
deficiencias en temas
telecomunicaciones qué significa esto
significa que yo no confío en el
internet significa que yo no puedo
apostar mi empresa mis aplicaciones de
misión crítica aquello con lo que yo
pero día a día no lo puedo apostar a un
enlace internet que podría fallar pero
no todas las aplicaciones realmente son
visión crítica ahora en sistemas como
generación de reportes que si se me cae
la internet y yo no pudieran reporte en
este momento sino que me tengo que
esperar una hora
realmente no pasa nada el mundo no se
acaba una solución entonces es llevar a
la nube allá afuera sólo aplicaciones
que no son misión crítica
otra alternativa es volvamos a ver hacia
adentro si nuestro problema es el acceso
a internet qué tal si más bien
comenzamos a aprovecharla existen
proveedores de nube que existen dentro
de nuestro territorio nacional a los
cuales nos podemos conectar aprovechando
la vasta red de anillos de fibra óptica
que tenemos en el país con mucha mayor
confiabilidad que el enlace externo
internet y entonces podemos aprovechar
las bondades de es cablear de la nube
pero dentro del territorio nacional
muy relacionado con esto la siguiente
barrera mencionada por las empresas es
un tema de rigidez regulaciones y
territorialidad territorialidad de los
datos a qué nos referimos con esto nos
referimos a leyes como el 89 68 que
tenemos aquí en costa rica que
expresamente prohíben a cualquier
empresa a hospedar datos de sus clientes
fuera del territorio nacional sin el
consentimiento escrito de los clientes
pues a las empresas que tienen este
temor les tengo 33 bemoles tres aristas
a considerar una primera es no todo lo
que nosotros hacemos en nuestras
empresas tienen que ver con datos de los
clientes piensen en cosas como un
catálogo de productos como vídeos de
capacitación como promociones de
mercadeo para estos asuntos yo no
necesito información que identifique a
mis clientes y por tanto no hay ley que
limite el que yo tenga estos datos fuera
del territorio nacional por otra parte
esta ley decía que no lo puedo hacer sin
el consentimiento escrito lo cual quiere
decir que nosotros conseguimos ese
consentimiento bien podemos ir afuera y
finalmente con el punto anterior
mencioné que hay productos de nueve
locales que podemos utilizar que también
son alternativa para aprovechar la
escalabilidad de la nueva migración
minimización del riesgo financiero sin
tener que sacar datos de nuestros
clientes del territorio nacional y una
última barrera que mencionan las
empresas como relevante para ellos es la
ausencia de un proveedor local y esto es
algo muy cultural muy latino muy
costarricense nosotros sentimos que
tenemos que lograr llamar a juan pérez y
gritar por el teléfono porque si yo no
lo puedo llamar para gritarle no me
están dando un buen servicio
necesitamos este esta persona cercana
hay una buena falsa por ahí que se
necesitó poder llegar al cuello para
ahorcarlo en caso de que yo me tenga que
dejar por mi servicio y si no tengo esta
cercanía con el cliente no siento que me
puedan dar un buen servicio
veo varios tests viéndose lo cual quiere
decir que hay alguien que abarcaron
seguramente o alguien ha gritado por
teléfono
esto yo lo veo como una oportunidad una
oportunidad para las empresas que deseen
innovar y comenzar a ofrecer este tipo
de servicios dentro del territorio
nacional
entonces si bien hay una serie de
barreras que en muchos casos están bien
fundadas son razonables variadas que no
queremos cruzar porque ponemos en riesgo
la operación de nuestras empresas
realmente si pensamos un poquito más son
barreras superables qué implica esto
implica que las bondades económicas de
la nube realmente están ahí la escala de
la nube la posibilidad de no tener que
invertir en capacidad ociosa la
posibilidad de poder innovar y
experimentar sin el riesgo financiero y
es que qué lindo es que yo pueda la nube
y con solo mi intelecto con solo mis
ideas yo pueda comenzar a probarlas
poquito a poco y si algo no funcionó
apago cierra la llave y después vuelve a
abrir la llave la nube realmente nos
permite innovar sin embargo hay algunos
detalles que de nuevo por tal vez por
temas de conocimiento y capacitación
tengamos que darle vuelta y sobrellevar
de otra manera y persona y me encanta
decir que la nube es para todos si no lo
estamos haciendo estamos desperdiciando
una grandísima oportunidad y nos estamos
quedando atrás como país como región sin
embar
es para todo así que lo que yo espero
que nos llevemos a nuestros hogares ya
nuestras empresas después de la charla
de hoy es que la próxima vez que estemos
pensando en un nuevo proyecto tecnología
de información la pregunta que nos
hagamos no es porque no podemos a la
nube sino también mira y por qué no
consideramos la nube les los dejo con
esta invitación muchísimas gracias